[Music]
in binge-watching you submitted by
honeydew for me I don't know I just
thought it sounded like that definitely
wrote it movie pass has updated their
business model offering daily theater
tickets for only $10 a month wanna be
even make any money I knew I was them
get you how does this work and I'm like
trap figure out myself it makes sense
because how many like how many real
people people but how many average
people go to the movie theater like like
how often are they going they're not
going every single month it depends
where they go every few months like for
example if you don't live in LA more
people actually go to the theater and do
those activities but how many time do
you think they're going a month I don't
know visually I don't really get out
there would probably like what five to
like eight bucks
our average eight eighty four oh okay
cool yeah so then for them like they're
making ten dollars every single month
consistently like that sounds pretty
good to me there are restricted times
you can go no so movie pass was started
in 2011 and originally it was like a $30
a month subscription where you can go
watch movies at the theaters and the
restrictions are that you can't watch 3d
you can only go to theaters that accept
debit cards because apparently is movie
passes use via like a debit card
transaction back then they would be
based on where the person lives and what
movie they want to watch depending on
what time and then they will give you
like a price of how much the ticket
would cost yeah it's like I'm personally
a little bit confused how exactly it
worked but now they're saying that the
co-founder of Netflix Mitch Lowe he
became CEO last year and so now recently
he just announced that they're dropping
down their monthly subscription price
from 15 to 50 dollars what it used to be
- now 995 a month and so they're saying
is that you can watch a movie a day for
you know the entire month for just $10
so it seems pretty crazy there a lot of
people are saying like oh you guys are
going to lose a ton of money with is
because
you know the average ticket is eight
dollars maybe four cents so it's like
it's interesting to see how they're
going to be making a profit on it
actually being it's genius you can some
of the people that we talk to that work
in the movie industry they said that
they actually don't make very much money
off the movies because the licensing for
the movies are [ __ ] expensive so for
example if you have an indie film and
you come into the theater they might
split the ticket sales 5050 70/30
whatever but when you have something
huge like Marvel that comes in
you might make $1 per ticket so per
movie you're making different amounts of
money which is why some movie theaters
only cater these movies and some of them
only cater to these movies where they
make the most money it's just like a gas
station and it's the concession stands
which is why the popcorn cost [ __ ] 50
bucks who are bottled water costs $1,000
that's the reason why I know they rate
these are make sense so now with this
because the movies are going to run
anyways like whether there's one person
in the movie theater or 300 they're
still going to play that movie but now
you're going to bring people in with ten
dollars a month and don't be spending
money on it's a sour patch kids and then
like the twist and it's guaranteed to
make that amount every month that's why
it's like genius and there's a lot of
people like me in this world that by
subscription things thinking I'm going
to use that [ __ ] and they just keep
taking money from me man that business
model that does that it is him yeah you
know I'm signed up to a couple of gyms a
couple and I yogi caught a bus and he
wasn't even signed up for that one he
goes to the region for the origin
there's two gyms that I work out at my
apartment and barbell and they're both
free Oh confusion the power ones not
that free you pay rent yeah hmm you
still pay for 24 that you had for like
15 years because you had the grandfather
not on that one they conveniently forgot
to [ __ ] call me to renew my goddamn
subscription because I had a really good
one I was paying 14 bucks a year
not every month for one year well that's
pretty good after these pay $700 yeah
because when I first signed up to write
check it we have this program where you
pay 700 bucks and it's like first
for like the first two or three years
but every year after that for a lifetime
you get 14 bucks a year and I'm all like
[ __ ] yeah
I thought you're crazy when you did that
700 bucks I know when we went together I
use we use our but you saw oh my god
yeah you're getting pretty buff yeah cuz
I was like 110 and I got really [ __ ]
fat because I would eat KFC after every
workout after every workout I didn't
know nutrition okay I just thought I
needed to [ __ ] eat because I was like
110 and I'm like I can't I can't even do
a bench press with 20 plates on the side
and I was like [ __ ] and then every time
I would like worked out I would go back
get some Taco Bell KFC get hungry as
[ __ ] and I just grow we would go work
out and then after working out we'd go
back to our friends house and wait his
mom's kitchen yeah get everything in the
fridge and just have a whole meal for
like an hour he was just being eat yeah
with like fast food you some pregnant
ass [ __ ]
crazy but there are saying though that
since having this movie passing that
attendant to movie theaters have gone up
111 percent point into them that's also
me and I mentioned earlier too and how
their customers tend to buy a lot more
concession items mm-hmm especially
psychologically you know that you didn't
pay like 15 bucks or take it you're
willing to spend a little more already
have my budget out for the night I might
as well buy more ice cream and stuff is
genius they must hate people like me
because I bring food in I bring my sodas
in once am i I hate people like you I
brought in one time a pizza slice
wrapped up in foil I thought like a box
no I cooked some pizza some DiGiorno at
home and then I put it in your father
cheapest way to make peace yeah but I
had to the freezer you knows last minute
but I bought the whole foil and I just
ate it in the theater but have you seen
that meme where those girls went in with
half cut watermelons and they pretended
they were pregnant and in the year
eating watermelon and the movie theater
masks watermelon I was like those are
kind of girls I want to be friends with
you want any warm water mud
you look any water moustache you're
talking to the wrong person you know
it's like I don't know him I think it's
a pretty good idea though I think it's a
great idea
I sense there's links to Casey's like
we're going to do love theater uh also
they've already announced the price job
but it's already been an ongoing thing
is it already existed it's available
everywhere it's uh yeah which theaters
participate apparently it's like 91
percent of the theaters is just whatever
chatter what about our Glee Z though
whatever
do you accept debit cards so I glanced I
thought everybody was got a debit card
this cash only did everyone okay for
special culture Chinese version I think
they're forgetting that there's a
existence outside of California there's
other states that do cash only
maybe it's like credit only what is it a
Chinese old theater haha there's movie
theaters out in California that is ten
bucks a month now and so it's this
membership of membership membership Oh
ten bucks okay and then you get to watch
one movie a day and then per membership
- it's not like like if we want to go
watch a movie you also have to have a
membership along with my membership if
we want to do this $10 one thing you
can't buy two tickets oh yeah you can
buy one that's cause I might not do you
guys remember those like discount
theaters so like the main theater at
beyond together like on the side they
have like the discount theaters of a
dollar movie yeah Edwards really Edwards
of the discount theater the one on our
line is the one on Atlantic now it's
like an NBC seafood next to the NBC
seafood Oh all the Chinese near a few
Chinese Mary knows are ever I would go
there watch angels in the outfield there
I'd watch a [ __ ] the goofy movie I
watched on this one with all that sticky
floor and then there's a rappers anyway
oh now long ago I love the discount the
Adhan anymore wow those $1 oh yeah did
you guys ever go to one of those
theaters where it's like all one level
like old school like all one that I want
the speeds are like they don't even
recline or anything that's like dad was
almost like that the dollar theater yeah
they always have sticky floors yeah no
one cleaned that one the people just
peopled spill soda icicle with my dad
that all the time because he takes me up
on Tuesdays because my precious Devore
your stories are so [ __ ] trash let's
go there and watch movies but also happy
because I couldn't watch TV at home oh
my hell yeah my dad seemed to watch
movies I know that was like a tradition
with my parents before the divorce to
everyone yeah we can go to the movie
theater no that was like my connection
with like my dad and I mean in KC I'm
like hey it's kind of true you do end up
getting with someone that reminds me of
your parents somehow capable of moving
my dad loves movies
my dad was obsessive Asian stuff case
evasion jaws obsessed with a Kaz oh
that's true my dad like beating me and I
love fighting hating people like your
parents Oh his model you know what I'm
crazy jess is similar to my grandma and
my grandma raised me well there are
elements with my mom in just two because
my mom is like OCD clean and so is Jess
or maybe they're just normal clean I'm
just [ __ ] filthy I think it's not one
maybe I do you guys think you'll get
this membership $10 a month down if my
favorite theaters are part of it in hell
yeah both to be gates they don't know
what they're talking about they're
excluded predict the next like two years
why you guys having a baby now you can't
go to the theater with new words no all
I need is membership any of the
membership ticket leaves don't be that
family that brings a [ __ ] baby to the
theater and those [ __ ] babies crying
[ __ ] now I'll never get through I'll be
at the hip and the late-night show you
know like those midnight showings and
[ __ ] and there's a [ __ ] baby I'm like
little [ __ ] brings a baby to the theatre
dude you know I would get so angry when
I would see like little babies like
under five years old and it's like 11
o'clock at night or midnight and I'm
like what the [ __ ] are they doing at
importantly maybe the parents kiss we
because the baby gonna cry all day long
and [ __ ]
are there shopping and getting groceries
in midnight it's like let your kid go to
something special as I get older though
it's easier for babysitting because you
don't have to watch the kiddies into the
movies and you can fall asleep all the
kids watching a movie and the kids going
to say mom dad can I watch it again yeah
of course you go for hours
you couldn't do that at home no you just
you just stay in the seats and watch it
again I'd run that for drastic park many
times I was like yeah let's watch it
again and of Mines knocked up yeah well
I don't know I'll get to the movie I
don't know what she was doing but most
likely not that hey guys thanks for
watching the last video make sure to
follow us on instagram @ JK films to
watch more videos right up there
[Music]
you